comme ça fout les jetons on est dans un
espèce de déni collectif on ne veut pas
croire ce qu'on sait et scientifique
parcomètres de la sixième extinction de
la vie sur terre
sixième extinction et la vie sur terre
y'a d'autres experts qui conteste
norouzi l'ordre de 6 personnes non non
c'est pas vrai il ya des climats tous et
non ce n'est pas il y en a pas il ya des
gens qui ne sont pas des chercheurs qui
parlent que la presse met en avant parce
que il faut que du débat le ya plus de
débat aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun
débat ce changement climatique
on va vers un autre est par une
catastrophe ou va vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimiste tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et les demis y en a
pas d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour une heure et demie d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités de nous évidemment
bonne distance et nos reporters une
émission essentiellement consacrée à la
crise du coronavirus en france et dans
le monde
voici les titres le plan de
déconfinement présenté par edouard
philippe cet après midi a été rejeté par
le sénat ce soir par 89 voix contre
contre et 81% 74 abstentions du manque
de masques de protection et de tests en
passant par la réouverture des écoles le
gouvernement fait face à de nombreuses
critiques concernant l'après 11 mai
alors que la barre des 25 mille décès a
été franchie la grande distribution
commence à commercialiser des masques
depuis aujourd'hui sans pour autant
éteindre la polémique
les soignants s'indigne de voir arriver
des dizaines de millions de masques dans
les rayons d'un jour à l'autre
edouard philippe affirmons qu'il n'y a
pas de stock caché
[Musique]
ailleurs en europe les pays goûte peu à
peu à une forme relative de liberté
retrouvée
l'italie entre dans sa deuxième phase de
déconfinement alors qu'en espagne les
habitants peuvent ressorti après 50
jours de confinement strict la
télévision chinoise
de son côté dément et les propos
apprécie donc du secrétaire d'état
américain mike pompéo sur l'origine de
la pandémie est liée au nouveau
coronavirus haut et ne reviendront sur
la crise du corps d'un virus qui touche
de plein fouet le milieu culturel
également les festivals sont annulés ou
reportés les ans après les autres les
salles de cinéma et de spectacles pnl à
se projeter sur une potentielle date de
réouverture emmanuel macron louis promet
des décisions le 6 mai
[Musique]
le sénat rejette donc ce soir le plan du
gouvernement à 89 voix contre 81 % 74
abstentions
edouard philippe en avait détaillé les
contours cet après midi au palais du
luxembourg on part tout de suite sur
place rejoint notre reporter thomas
bonnet bonsoir
thomas que faut-il donc retenir de cette
intervention cet après midi une journée
plutôt délicate pour le gouvernement
puisque vous l'avez dit le sénat rejette
le plan de déconfinement présenté
aujourd'hui par edouard philippe 89 voix
contre 81 une voie pour 174 abstention
en clair la droite s'est abstenue et la
gauche a voté contre dans ce qui
constitue un vote non contraignant et
dont la portée est avant tout symbolique
les sénateurs donc pas convaincu par le
discours du premier ministre un discours
d'environ une heure au cours duquel
edouard philippe a détaillé un certain
nombre de mesures des mesures
économiques avec par exemple une aide de
200 euros pour huit cent mille jeunes en
situation de précarité des mesures
sanitaires avec par exemple l'objectif
de 700 mille tests par semaine ainsi que
le fait que chaque français puisse se
procurer un masque à la date du 11 mai
de philipp koehn a profité pour répondre
à cette polémique sur d éventuels stocks
cachés de masques pour ce qui concerne
la grande distribution il a également
précisé la doctrine en matière de port
de masques dans les écoles on écoute aux
personnels de l'éducation nationale et
aux collégiens
pour ces derniers le masque sera
obligatoire quand les restes de
distanciation sociale risque de ne pas
être respectés pour les élèves des
classes élémentaires le port du masque
n'est pas recommandé il est même
proscrit pour les enfants de maternelle
et j'aimerais répondre aux malentendus
qui a échauffé ce week-end quelques
esprits
peut-être en mal de politiques je dois
dire que je peine à comprendre quel
intérêt aurait eu la grande distribution
a caché des stocks de masques au lieu de
les vendre en temps de pénurie il n'y a
pas et il n'y a jamais eu de stock caché
il y a des commandes massives et il faut
un certain temps avant qu'elle se
concrétise en millions de masques
disponibles pour l'ensemble de
concitoyens suite à ce discours
l'opposition a fait part d'un certain
nombre de réserves notamment donc sur la
question des masques et plus
généralement sur les contradictions du
gouvernement contradictions entre les
discours qui était tenue au début de
cette crise du comique 19 et les
discours qu'y sont tenues actuellement
par l'exécutif propose d'écouter
quelques-uns des membres de l'opposition
ici au sénat la confiance ne se décrète
pas elle se mérite
or monsieur le premier ministre vous
avez largement entamé votre capital
confiance auprès de l'opinion publique
depuis le début de cette crise les
françaises et les français sont à sayid
injonctions contradictoires
nous ne pouvons plus vous croire sur
parole parce que cette parole a fait
l'objet de trop de contradictions de
trop de contre vérités parfois aussi
vous auriez dû dire dès le départ qu'il
y avait un problème de pénurie il faut
en finir avec les injonctions
contradictoires que nous connaissons
depuis plusieurs mois vous n'avez pas
anticipé ce désarroi des parents des
enseignants des élus en manque de
confiance qui s'est donc traduit par un
rejet du plan de confinement dans le
vote qui avait lieu cet après midi au
sénat ce vote était uniquement
consultatif il ne devrait donc pas
contraindre l'exécutif à revoir sa
stratégie en revanche ils augurent de
quelques difficultés à venir sur le vote
d'un autre texte puisque le sénat est
amené à s'exprimer ce soir sur le projet
de loi qui va proroger l'état d'urgence
sanitaire pour une période de deux mois
avec notamment la mise en place de
mesures telles que les brigades
sanitaires qui vont être créés pour
collecter des données sur les malades et
sur leur entourage ou encore la mise en
quarantaine pour les personnes qui
arrivent sur le territoire national
c'est une mesure qui avait été annoncée
samedi à l'issue du conseil des
ministres et qui a été corrigé depuis
puisque l'elysée a fait savoir hier que
finalement cette mesure ne concernera
pas les personnes issues de l'espace
schengen et du royaume uni
les débats devraient donc être animée
puisque au total ce sont 160 amendements
qui ont été déposés sur ce projet de loi
un sénateur me confier tout à l'heure
qu'il s'attend à des débats qui
pourraient durer jusque très tard ce
soir voire très tôt demain matin
merci thomas bonnin en direct donc dû
senna est le port du masque après
déconfinement sera donc obligatoire dans
certains cas par exemple dans les
transports et depuis ce matin on peut
s'en procurer dans les grandes surfaces
des masques chirurgicaux mais aussi en
tissu sont commercialisés dans certains
magasins de la grande distribution et ça
fait polémique les professionnels de la
santé demandent des explications sur ses
livraisons qui interviennent alors que
le personnel hospitalier monk lui de
protection est la vente de masques a
donc débuté on vient de le dire dans
certaines grandes surfaces notamment à
paris illustration au carrefour portes
auteuil comment ça se passe
combien ça coûte écouter certaines de
ses réactions
c'est bien et ça aurait pu être fait
avant c'est surtout ça pour présenter sa
carte de
de fidélité pour avoir de deux pochon de
cinq matches oui il faut présenter la
carte pour en obtenir la carte de
fidélité
donc c'est dur pour ceux qui n'ont pas
la carte parce que tout le monde
enfin je veux dire c'est pas une
obligation d'avoir une carte de fidélité
une fois qu'on a fait nos courses on
passe aux caisses et on demande si on
veut un masque ou si on veut pas moi
j'en ai pris deux vastes pour moi et
pour ma fille tout simplement mais de
toute façon je crois pas qu'il donne au
plus à ses 5 par personne c'est des
petits paquets de 5
donc c'est raisonnable et c'est
distribué par personne c'est bien parce
que d'antiques dans tous les pays on
peut acheter sauf en france on pouvait
pas les acheter juste aujourd'hui notre
y chanter en allemagne un peu on peut
pas tout acheter sauf en france et
aujourd'hui voilà c'est bien il faut
demander dans les caisses sont pas en
libre service à 128 5 mars nombre de
paquets mais il aurait fallu le faire
bien bien avant c'est scandaleux
je pense que c'est un peu le parcours du
combattant puisqu'il faut demander aux
caissiers aux caissières de voilà de
nous donner des masques mais je ne sais
pas par combien et je ne sais pas
comment mais voilà je pense que c'est au
compte gouttes quand même sens mais
trouve pas ailleurs c'est bien moi je me
donnais que 5
on m'a donné j'aurais payé mais c'était
5 ou par courrier c'est ce qu'a demandé
à la caisse mais ça coûte 90 centimes la
masca vous faites le compte de ces mêmes
passe encore on vous croquer et pour en
parler nous sommes avec renaud muselier
président de la région paca bonsoir à
renaud muselier merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france on vous étiez je
ne sais pas si vous voulez toujours un
président de région très en colère ce
week-end samedi vous avez donné
concrètement trois jours à la grande
distribution pour s'expliquer sur cette
vente massive de masse à ce que déjà
vous avez eu des réponses
bon je suis pas du tout en colère je
suis la colère est mauvaise conseillère
je suis très attentif sur ce qui se
passe est la vigie ca suivant et aux
annonces dans mon pays ça fait deux mois
que nous sommes en guerre pour les
masques et maintenant une forme de
guerre de communication pour savoir si
ces masques seront ont été fabriquées et
cas c'est vrai que c'est très inquiétant
si sport
pourquoi vous avez fait un reportage que
tout à fait intéressant par exemple chez
carrefour cet après-midi le masque a été
fabriqué un 1er avril l'autorisation du
gouvernement pour faire bloquer les
masques date du 24 avril entre le 24
avril et le cas prenez vous avez deux
week-ends avec le pont du 1er mai qui
est obligé ou trois jours fériés en
chine c'était que moi comment on peut
fabriquer des masques défendre sur le
territoire français pendant que nous les
cherchons dans les pharmacies pour les
médecins pour les pharmaciens dans les
hôpitaux où il ya une pénurie internet
ou encore aujourd'hui les infirmer un
moment que 18 dans chacune des
formations dotation de la rs et d'un
coup on se retrouve avec une pluie de
plusieurs centaines de millions de marks
annoncé près d'un milliard réservé 70
millions en boutique
donc il ya quand même quelque chose que
c'est assez inquiétant là dedans et donc
la question est simple pour j'ai demandé
j'ai mis en demeure les grands groupes
de mettre 20 août qui sont transparents
mais ils vont nous donner simplement les
bons de commande des bons de livraison
pour aller prier on aura les dates des
avions l'état dédouanement et on verra à
ce moment-là si l'on stocké à bord en
chine ou en france et comment ils ont
ramené renaud muselier
michel edouard leclerc vous a répondu ce
week-end pour lui il n'y a pas de stock
caché c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous a dit
également en tout cas ce qu'a dit aux
sénateurs edouard philippe cet
après-midi et s'exprime dans une vidéo
sur son site internet il parle même
d'une polémique débile et côté temps des
élus probablement bien attentionnés mais
qu'ils disent
alors d'abord il y en a qu il trouve ça
scandaleux que ce soit des supermarchés
qui vend des masques qu'ils regardent
qui fasse le tour du monde c'est des
débats il ya qu'il ya qu'en france pour
sa part tout que ce soit singapour que
ce soit aux états unis à taiwan en
allemagne ou en grande bretagne
on trouve des masques à tous les étals
que ce soit chez les buralistes que ce
soit dans les pharmacies où que ce soit
dans les épiceries et les supermarchés
par contre je chante en plus des élus
comme monsieur muselier ou
où le maire de bordeaux qui eux ne
comprennent pas que aujourd'hui on est
des masques alors qu' il ya un mois il
avait du mal à doter leurs hôpitaux mais
oui mais c'était il ya un mois et depuis
toute la production chinoise s'est remis
en branle et même là la filière
française
c'est maintenant qu'il commence à
produire ou qu'ils produisent en grande
quantité faut pas faire procès de michel
edouard leclerc qui prend le temps de
vous répondre est ce que vous êtes
convaincu oeuvre de muselier par cette
réponse convaincu dans la question avant
parce que je m'inquiète beaucoup
monsieur doit bloquer un michel edouard
leclerc pour des jugements sur les élus
c'est bien je peux pas dû je m'en rends
moi c'est la grande distribution
est ce la voie en compagnie monsieur
leclerc va sûrement juste prise qu'il
faut il traiter normalement
vraisemblalement très bien son personnel
c'est évident et c'est tout à fait
reconnu donc moi je porte pas de
jugement là dessus
seule chose qui est vraiment important
que c'est c'est pas de savoir si dans le
monde entier au monde et masques
heureusement comme on est en manque des
matches en entier sur que dans le monde
entier il ya aussi des matchs pour les
soignants et nous ça fait deux mois
qu'on n'a pas de masque pour les
soignants quand il nous dit qu'il ya un
mois la tension était on pouvait
commander en chine ce prix il ya un mois
c'est exactement l'inversé les
américains qui sont venus nous piquer
nos masques en chine
la tension était absolument énorme ce
marché chinois il n'y avait pas de
places dans les avions
alors comment il a fait pour les faire
venir il est sûrement très fort ce
magicien et écoutez je vais j'attends
avec impatience quand on passe puis si
la section de lui c'est pas très
compliqué une grosse entreprise qui est
très connu et kiko tf1 je ne sais pas
il nous donne les bonnes comme horn et
prouve ainsi qu'il est tout à fait
transparent et il n'a pas fait une
préparation d'une plante c'est quand il
aura l'autorisation
en attendant que les médecins et
soignants à et la peur au ventre
prendrait dans les hôpitaux à la grande
distribution mais ce que l'état
clairement n'a pas un rôle à jouer
n'avait pas un rôle à jouer de
régulateur dans cette affaire vous avez
vu que je fais partie de ceux qui depuis
départ le zéro polémique avec l'état
c'est d'état en randonnée
pleinement raison à la grande
distribution et ceci comprend des
soignants qui sont là depuis deux mois
c'est pas très bien si ces gens qu'elle
soit messieurs le caire mme la ministre
on nous tape et 20 heures dehors pour
solliciter les soignants je suis pas sûr
qu'ils ont bien vu à la télévision qu'il
y avait une guerre des masques dans le
monde et qui avait aucun moyen d'y
accéder
s'il monsieur leclerc était si fort une
réponse est plus nous tendre la main
pour essayer nous aider pour nous
dépatouiller dans les régions de france
où on a commandé 60 4 mio et moi 15
millions pendant région commencent à de
côte d'azur où j'ai donné directement 3
millions et de mieux vous adresse et
ceci gratuitement pendant que monsieur
leclerc
les vents dans ses supermarchés et qui
devront donc encore beaucoup pour la
santé mais c'est pas le problème
il en faut des masses pour tout le monde
de transport d'en revenir il faut du
vent que je n'ai simplement savoir à
quel moment ils ont été fabriqués avant
de savoir si pendant que nous on souffre
et en première ligne elle n'était
capable de la ce moment là avec toutes
les équipes de la grande distribution de
faire des stocks en attendant pour les
vins sur ce plan la question mais qui
nous fournissent les bons de commande et
les bons des maisons avec des transports
carbo on y voir était alors autres début
de polémique
renaud muselier le prix 1 de ce masque
chirurgical qui est plafonné à 95
centimes d'euro l'ufc que choisir
par la voix de son président critique et
il achète pour lui le budget est tout
simplement intenable pour certains
foyers
pour vous est-ce un bon prix moi je suis
pour commerciaux des masques selon
chercher ça soit tout simplement gratuit
comme ça les bailleurs dans certaines
communes on est dessus gratuitement non
chacun fait ce qu'il peut et ce qu'il a
mais on a une pénurie importante des
mois je pense aux soignants à tous ceux
qui par exemple un pharmacien qui a
refusé toutefois à des gens malades
mourraient santé qui pouvait pas vendre
ces masques ne pouvait pas les donner
bon eh bien c'est comme ça ça c'est hier
et ce que je sais c'est un intermédiaire
qui matière souci est de savoir si au
delà de la loi si elle était respectée a
pas mal de les pages il voit les masques
carrefour aujourd'hui ouvre au delà de
la morale quand même que le pavillon
perdre un peu de morale savoir si ils
ont mis dix sont organisés pour être
prêt dès qu'ils pouvaient le faire
et ça même des repères et ça mais ça me
choque profondément a effectivement une
dernière question renaud muselier vous
le savez le sénat a rejeté ce soir dans
ce plan de déconfinement présenté par
edouard philippe une réaction peut-être
les sénateurs sont trop dures pour vous
la priorité aujourd'hui n'était pas de
des confiné où ils ont eu raison
finalement je pense qu'il faut des
confiné il faut que je pense qu'il faut
se battre pour trouver ces libertés que
il faut arrêter de poser des questions
supplémentaires derrière une autre
question supplémentaire pour des
questions complémentaires nous avec des
régions de france on ait pris une
position très constructive en disant
nous on pose une question on apporte une
réponse systématiquement ce qui permet
de traiter des problèmes des uns et les
autres nous on veut retrouver notre
liberté voilà moi je ne suis pas fait
pour être enfermés et on est un grand
nombre en france comme ça aussi c'est
dire maintenant il faut sortir de cette
situation il faut reprendre en liberté
en gardant c'est le geste du sensation
cela dans les mers ou mettant des du gel
mais il faut s'en sortir et donc
aujourd'hui au sénat a eu lieu c'est un
vote politique les gens devant les
membres de la famille politique et l'air
se sont abstenus donc c'est pas eux qui
ont fait obstacle
bon moi je pense que dans ces moments
difficiles et c'est très difficile pour
le premier ministre se retrouve dans ces
moments là c'est pas à peine de
compliquer encore plus la situation
il faut surtout que le la carte numéro
un c'est à dire la transmission du virus
en france deviennent bien verte
ça sera au moins un gage de sécurité
pour un des confirmands rapide merci
renaud muselier d'avoir été avec mon
direct assure rt france merci à vous et
la barre des 25 mille morts liés aux
kovy 19 était franchie aujourd'hui en
france le pays déplore 25200 un décès la
direction générale de la santé annonce
ces dernières 24 heures une hausse du
nombre de morts 2 306 du côté de la
carte le département de l'ardèche passe
en verre en raison de la diminution de
la circulation du virus avec une
proportion de passages aux urgences pour
kobe 19 inférieur à la barre des 6% est
la pandémie du courant navires us met à
mal les décisions du gouvernement
ce qu'annonce est inutile puis rendue
obligatoire pour le déconfinement
absence massive de thèse fermeture
tardive des frontières confinement
lancer sur le tard l'état at il fauté en
à gestion de la crise c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir et pour en
parler
nous sommes en direct avec fabrice di
vizio avocats des professions de santé à
l'origine d'ailleurs de plusieurs
plaintes contre le gouvernement à ses
côtés philippe bessette président de la
fédération des syndicats pharmaceutiques
de france bonsoir à vous aussi merci
d'être avec nous première question
messieurs vous avez sans doute écouté
edouard philippe
aujourd'hui le 11 mai évidemment plan de
déconfinement sauf si les français
manifestement se relâchent première
question est ce que cela vous semble
crédible
ses premiers pas vers le déconfinement
dans une semaine
à mon sens aller mais c'est une bouffée
de carole les on voit qu'il pose de
graves problèmes des gens qui sont
isolées pour on a parlé des personnes
âgées en ehpad qu'ils peuvent plus voir
personne n'en a parlé de nombreuses
autres problèmes de santé des
renoncements aux soins de gens qui
n'osent pas aller chez leur médecin
donc en termes de santé unique c'est
clair qu'il faut idéalement en toutes
précautions aller vers des confinement
et bien sûr en termes économiques
on sait pas vraiment mon sujet en tant
qu' en tant que pharmacien mais c'est le
sujet de tous en tant que citoyens
évidemment on ne peut pas continuer
longtemps à rester tous chez soi elles
ont pu va falloir apprendre la prudence
apprendre des gestes d'hygiène qu'on
avait un peu découvert à l'occasion de
cette épidémie mais qui sont très utiles
pendant tout le règne de notre notre vie
en suisse une réaction moi pour ma part
ce que je considère ces que prend le
problème à l'envers
on vous dit il faut bien sortir du
déconfinement évidemment qu'il faut
sortir de déconfinement mais peut-être
qu'on n'est pas obligé si vous voulez
d'en sortir n'importe comment c'est à
dire que c'est toujours le même problème
depuis le départ on est guidé par un
élément qu'on a oublié c'est
l'incertitude
on ne sait rien alors je sais bien que
certains spéculent sur l'absence de
deuxième drague et tant mieux si c'est
pas le cas
mais la politique c'est espérer le
meilleur et préparer au pire et c'est
exactement ce qu'on ne fait pas montre m
expliquer qu'il faut ce dès qu'on finit
bien sûr qu'il faut se déconfit nez mais
on est en train de m'expliquer qu'il
faut que tout le monde est un masque
pour les confiner parce que vous pensez
que le 11 mai tout le monde aura un
masque dans mes choix arrêté cinq
minutes on est sur une décision qui est
purement politique qui est purement
arbitraire on a dit le 11 mai comment on
aurait pu dire le 10 ou le vin et la
vérité effectivement c'est que
concrètement bas on n'est pas prêt et on
serait pas plus près sous réserve qu'on
soit réellement des confiner le
mouvement parce que je vous rappelle
quand même
qui a dit qu'on réévalue pas les choses
de cette semaine alors le relais
masculin justement c'est un peu le sujet
sensible en ce moment chez les
pharmaciens philippe vayssettes est-ce
que vous justement vous faites partie de
ces personnes qui ont été choqués on a
bu renaud muselier tout à l'heure c'est
au néant le mot est faible de ce stock
massif tout d'un coup à disposition de
la grande distribution en ce sens l'état
aurait dû également agir réguler regin
réquisitionnées selon vous c'est ce que
je les dis en fait le principe de celle
de cette pénurie de produit n'est pas la
régulation la réglementation est un
outil mais là la chose qui compte c'est
le nombre de masques qui existent sur le
territoire qu'ils soient dans les stocks
publics ou privés le nombre de bases qui
existent je parle des batteries mais
l'idée est là trio risation de ces
menaces la priorisation de ces matches
qui doivent aller bon on l'a dit aux
soignants aux aidants familiaux aux gens
qui sont travaillées aux côtés de noël
les personnes âgées fragiles et ensuite
aux personnes valides
tout ça ça ferme besoin 250 millions de
masques dans le ciel par semaine dans le
circuit médical personnel soignant
personnes fragiles au-delà de cela de ce
chiffre de 150 millions par semaine le
reliquat beau servi rodez confinement
est ce qui nous a heurtés c'est que les
masques sur les dotations d'état ou sur
le budget de la sécu on va dire ne sont
pas disponibles mois à ce jour je suis
sur une consigne direction générale de
la santé du 20 avril pour lequel je n'ai
pas le droit de donner de masques du
stock et à aux personnes même sort
devant une consigne claire dont les
bases sont à bloc et à ne parle pas des
masses mais j'ai pu acheter je parle des
masques du stock et à la consigne du
va'a bridge et rome salomon donc dire
que génère la santé c'est l'interdiction
de donner des bases même sans
prescription médicale
ma demande c'est que cette consigne
change et que je puisse donner des
masques stocks et à sur prescription
médicale et aux personnes fragiles dont
le jeu comme l'est parce qu'on la liste
est très précise de son délit les gens
qui avec la carte vitale je sais à qui
je dois donner un pacte chirurgicale
exactement six ans philippe vayssettes
pardonnez moi cette question un peu
provocatrice peut-être est-ce que vous
n'avez pas eu le sentiment quand même
les pharmaciens vous écoute et que vous
êtes fait un petit peut avoir sur ce
coup là parce que voilà je reviens à mon
précédent sujet ses millions et ses
millions de masques qui sont désormais
voilà dans la grande distribution dans
les supermarchés alors que vous voilà
vous semblez encore très contraint
notamment par des directives
gouvernementales comment vous vous
l'expliquer alors on peut on peut se
séparer le sujet en deux mois je vous
parle du stock de l'acheteur public
je vous parle de ce que l'état d'en
prendre en charge au titre de la
solidarité nationale
par ailleurs il y a le les achats et les
uns et les autres ont pu faire qui sont
des masques dont dépend qui demande et
parce que le tissu des masques
alternatifs et des masques chirurgicaux
il était tout à fait possible
d'acheter depuis donc le 23 mars et qui
sont donc en train d'arriver sur le
territoire ce que je ce que l'on pense
là dessus c'est que la grande distri
c'est faire un coup de pub sur notre dos
puisqu'en fait jeudi ils ont annoncé qu'
il avec 225 millions de masques locke
170 l'autre 150 millions et dimanche on
a appris qu en fait en réalité en stock
en stock en france il y en avait que
quelques millions et que le reste et
allait arriver un peu comme ce que nous
dit le ministre de la santé il 60d nous
dit il a acheté 2 milliards 8 2 mars
2008 c'est pareil mais dès 2008 il les a
achetés mais qui sont pas sur le sol
national
reprenons moi j'ai un leit motiv st j'ai
besoin d'abord d'une dotation pour les
soignants pour les patients sur
ordonnance patients fragiles qui vient
soit du stop est en soi une prise en
charge par l'assurance maladie on a
compris message en a peut-être laissé
parler pardonnez-moi empêche que ça vous
avez la parole à bonbons temps fabrice
division le renvoyer au néant tout envoi
la réponse peut-être à philippe
vayssettes la réponse est que monsieur
bessette fait la sophistique ni plus ni
moins monsieur mais c'était un sophiste
c'est à dire que concrètement monsieur
17 détourne le débat voulu poser est
effectivement une question précise
et comme il est embarrassé par la
réponse et je vais y venir
eh bien il vient effectivement faire du
compassionnel et vous expliquer
l'importance de privilégier les
soignants et notamment vous parle des
stocks d'état mais problème dont parle
monsieur muselier notamment et le
problème de la grande distribution n'a
rien à voir avec les stops d'état les
appels
plus exactement la tribune commune des
ordres professionnels n'a rien à voir
avec les stocks d'état c'est pas ça le
débat
la grande distribution la vérité
effectivement qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
est là exactement fait ce que les
pharmaciens auraient pu faire depuis le
23 mai qu'on leur a interdit de faire
prétendument au moins c'est à dire que
c'est bien les organes représentatifs de
la profession de pharmacien qui depuis
le 23 vous explique sans discontinuer
que les pharmaciens n'ont pas le droit
d'acheter des masques
c'est depuis effectivement sans
discontinuer depuis le 23 que la
profession explique à ses membres qu'il
est interdite vous vous souvenez de ce
pharmacien monsieur felou je crois sur
le plateau de jean marc morandini qui
expliquait on parle du coup de pub de
leclerc ou que sais-je
comment faut-il qualifié le fait qu'un
pharmacien vienne sur un plateau télé
expliqué que les grossistes répartiteurs
vont braver les interdictions de l'état
est effectivement aller acheter des
masques alors qu'il savait pertinemment
que ces interdictions n'existait pas la
question elle est là quand même
elle est quand même un moment donné on
me parle des dindons de la farce que
sont les pharmaciens bien sûr que les
pharmaciens sont les dindons de la farce
mais on pourrait raisonnablement se
poser la question de savoir à cause de
qui on a littéralement menti à toute une
profession qui raisonnablement et qui de
bonne foi croyez qu'elle n'avait pas le
droit de passer par ces centrales
d'achat pour effectivement acheté des
masques et aujourd'hui comme un forme
comme la profession s'est fait doubler
elle vient vouloir réquisitionner les
masques que elle même aurait souhaité
vendre la vérité c'est que la profession
de pharmacien s'est littéralement fait
avoir que concrètement au nom du
gentleman agreement vous avez vu cet
article hier ou des grossistes e10 bas
nous on savait qu'on n'avait pas le
droit
la question qu'il faut poser à monsieur
17 c est ce que oui ou non vous saviez
que vous aviez le droit ou non de vendre
des masques parce qu'avec une réponse
possible
oui ou non si c'est oui bah alors si
vous installez vous avez le droit de
vendre des masques pourquoi vos
pharmaciens les pharmaciens disait le
contraire
et pourquoi
l'ambiguïté a été savamment entretenue
et que l'ordre professionnel à dimanche
car non non non
me dites pas que c'est pas le cas vous
avez fait des communications votre ordre
et des communications sur ce point non
mais parvient non mais peut-être je suis
l'organisation professionnelle des
pharmaciens je suis en réunion serait
super professionnel
alors c'est à ce titre que vous
interroge vous êtes effectivement
responsable de vos écrits
alors je vous interroge avez-vous
effectivement passé la consigne selon
laquelle ou au moins effectivement
l'instruction selon laquelle non les
pharmaciens il était faux de prétendre
qu'il n'avait pas le droit d'acheter des
masques et avec vous effectivement à ce
qu'il disait à vos organisations qui
disait que les pharmaciens n'avez pas le
droit de vendre des masques avez vous
répondu publiquement qu'il en avait le
droit
les teufeurs différents oui messieurs en
24h aux commandes parce que c'est vrai
qu'à question c'est quand même il
répondait elle s'est rapidement fini
bessette
oui parce que j'ai des écrits donc dès
le début le 17 avril 17 avril
j'ai envoyé des messages très clairs
pour dire dès le 23 mars j'ai appris les
grossistes répartiteurs pour leur dire
qu'ils avaient le droit d'acheter des
masses jusqu'à aller jusqu'à une limite
de cinq millions et que pour le reste il
fallait qu'ils demandent au ministère de
la santé un agrément dès le 17 avril
j'ai demandé à mes pharmaciens pour bébé
les grossistes répartiteurs dans l'eure
dans leurs achats
je leur ai dit vous avez le droit
d'acheter des masses vous devez acheter
des masques
la question de la vente est une autre
question
la question de la vente la question de
la vente est une autre question que
celle de l'achat je leur ai dit dès le
17 avril vous donnerai ma maman bon et
on en finira sur 7 le schapi des matchs
est ce que j'aimerais me fait réagir sur
un autre sujet également puisque voix
c'est vrai que la question était est ce
que l'état commis des fautes
aujourd'hui on a une députée la
république en marche qui a voté contre
ce plan de déconfinement proposé par son
gouvernement
martin
venayre c'est son nom au député du bas
rhin qui explique qu'il n'a aucune
stratégie thérapeutique
selon elle on n'a pas laissé tout
simplement les médecins à prescrire les
médicaments qu'ils auraient dû prescrire
qu'il souhaitait prescrire j'avais envie
d'avoir votre avis de pharmaciens
philippe bessette et ensuite celui de
l'avocat qui on le rappelle a posé a
déposé plusieurs plaintes contre le
gouvernement philippe b 7 mois sur ce
sujet du traitement
j'espère qu'il va y avoir un traitement
le plus rapidement possible je suis très
content qu'il y ait de multiples études
qui donne des traitements prometteurs
mon rôle à moi c'est en tant que
pharmacien c'est le bien sûr de m'en
tenir à ce que dit la science au jour de
la connaissance de la sar dont pour
répondre très précisément à la question
il y a eu donc un débat sur les drogues
si leurs hôtes il
il y a eu un débat sur la nicotine
il y à un débat sur plusieurs comptes et
viraux tous et tous ces débats qui sont
des recherches sont des recherches sont
menées à l'hôpital quand elles ne sont
pas abouti moi je ne vais pas donner de
la nicotine plus de la plus de la ligue
roc cyclo rockin +2 antiviral plus des
antibiotiques qui peut qui ont des
beaucoup d'effets secondaires à une
personne qui a peur d'avoir le
coronavirus c'est assez simple donc dès
qu'il y aura je l'espère je l'attends le
plus rapidement possible dès qu'il y
aura un traitement
évidemment je le donnerai ça ne veut pas
dire que l'état ne doit pas produire au
cas où
parce que ce qui serait le pire du pire
c'est que le jour où on dit ce
traitement marche en ait pas de stock
donc tant pis il faut lancer les chaînes
de production
parce que si jamais au moment où on dit
ça marche
imaginons les rôtis planty ou à l'autre
et que le ensuite on nous tease
il faut un an pour produire ah ben non
le mot de la fin fabrice di vizio sur ce
point le mot de la fin c'est qu'on fait
pas de la médecine à la télé c'est tout
c'est à dire que concrètement on fait
pas de la médecine
tout simplement c'est une députée la
république a voté contre le plan ce
s'interroge me suis effectivement on
n'est pas là pour analyser l'efficacité
tel ou tel médicament que je vous dis
par rapport à la députée c'est que
concrètement les médecins ils ont une
liberté de prescription qui est là même
qu'ils ont toute l'année il ya un débat
autour de la prescription des rôtis
chloroquine c'est le seul médicament
soit les médecins ne puisse pas plus le
prescrire et effectivement elle peut le
déplorer à déplorer mais la vérité c'est
que la science l avance avec prudence et
qu' il faut faire très attention
effectivement a partout dans une
dictature de l'opinion du ca marche
aujourd'hui bas hiroki chloroquine oui
effectivement c'est une piste
intéressante
incontestablement le taux silice du mahb
en est une autre
on a comme le disait monsieur une
multitude effectivement d'essais
cliniques en cours
gardons nous bien de faire de la
médecine de la place des médecins merci
bon concentre à deux mois de la fin
fabrice di vizio philippe vayssettes
d'avoir été avec moi pour ce face à face
merci à vous et ailleurs en europe
l'espagne ans elle a commencé son
déconfinement ce week-end depuis samedi
les espagnols ont pu ressortir après 50
jours de confinement street les
explications à barcelone avec les images
j'ai signé leslie singla sur le récit de
clémence pital
distribution de masques à l'entrée de
cette station de métro de la capitale
catalane
depuis ce lundi le port du masque dans
les transports en commun est obligatoire
près de six millions de masques ont déjà
été distribués par la police et la garde
civile dont les principales stations de
métro et arrêts de bus du pays
non cela me faisait peur de prendre le
métro car il y a des gens qui ne mettait
pas de masque ni de gants en plus je
fais de mon âge et de mes problèmes
respiratoires j'ai encore plus peur
je pense que le masque devrait être
obligatoire partout pendant les
premières phases du déconfinement dans
d'autres pays les gens le font déjà
quand ils ont la grippe ou un rhume
ici on doit prendre l'habitude aussi et
on va être obligé de la prendre
maintenant l'espagne aborde ce que le
gouvernement a baptisé la fa0 du
déconfinement de nouvelles mesures
rentrent désormais en vigueur comme la
levée de rideau pour les salons de
coiffure des boutiques et d'autres
entreprises jugées non essentielles
prochain objectif pour l'espagne pour
suivre le déconfinement tout en
consolidant la baisse de la courbe
d'infection dans le pays et l'italie
poursuit elle aussi sondé confinement la
deuxième phase a démarré aujourd'hui les
conditions de déplacement se sont
assouplies des milliers d'italiens
peuvent ainsi se rendre à nouveau sur
leur lieu de travail faire du sport ou
encore rendre visite à certains membres
de leur famille
la prudence reste de mise en ce pays où
on le rappelle 29 mille personnes ont
trouvé la mort lié au virus en libye
elle la queue dont les transports
les italiens reprennent depuis ce lundi
leurs vieilles habitudes bus métro
boulot le port du masque est exigée mais
une impression domine le soulagement à
ouchy reste
c'était un sentiment positif d'aller au
travail ce matin après deux mois à la
maison c'était agréable
il ya toujours un peu de peur mais j'ai
été rassuré par ce que j'ai vu dans le
métro tout le monde porter des masques à
gaz et commençons la phase 2 de manière
positive
nous devrons être forts et capables de
nous adapter à cette situation pour
revenir le plus rapidement possible à
une vie normale
[Musique]
l'italie est donc entré dans la deuxième
partie de son déconfinement 4,4 millions
de personnes sont attendues sur les
chantiers dans les bureaux les usines ou
encore les boutiques stefano par exemple
a rouvert sa papeterie
non sans quelques inquiétudes
apparaissent au piano fait dire à mots
et je dois tout désinfecter
j'ai déjà des masques les clients
doivent entrer dans le magasin en
emportant au masque et respecter une
distance de sécurité
si j'y arrive j'achèterai du gel
désinfectant pour les mains
le gouvernement nous a donné 600 euros
d'argent de poche
il aurait pu faire plus c'est sûr mais
c'est mieux que rien avant une
réouverture complète le 1er juin les
bars et les restaurants proposent dès
aujourd'hui des plans porté à bol d'air
frais pour des italiens motorisée de
nouveau à se promener et à faire de
l'exercice à l'extérieur nous sommes
heureux parce qu'enfin aujourd'hui ils
ont rouvert la villa borghèse et après
l'avoir fermé pendant un mois et demi
même si évidemment ma fille a été déçu
de trouver l'accès au terrain de jeu
complètement interdite un seul mot
d'ordre dans le pays distant session
sociale les forces de l'ordre sont très
présents dans les rues et lieux de
transport
il est désormais possible de rendre
visite à ses proches à condition qu'ils
vivent dans la même région une
attestation est toujours de rigueur pour
justifier ses déplacements une troisième
phase est attendu le 18 mai avec
notamment la réouverture des commerces
mais aussi des bibliothèques des musées
et des lieux culturels et quel est
l'état d'esprit des italiens sur place
éléments de réponse avec solène tadié
journalistes basés en tête une essuie
une échéance 13
tendue près deux mois de confinement
strict dans le pays aurait vite et je
dirais qu'il s'agit moins d'un des
confinement de la population que d'une
reprise des activités productives qui
concerne pour l'heure environ 4 millions
d'italiens et qui se poursuivra de
manière graduelle ces prochaines
semaines pour gouvernement craint
beaucoup le fameux risque de deuxième
vague du virus une peur qui est très
très répandu en dans toute l'europe et
donc à cet effet le gouvernement met
tout en oeuvre je dirais pour limiter
les occasions de rassemblements ce qui a
pour effet de rendre cette phase numéro
2 assez délicate est restreinte
il s'agit d'une reprise relativement à
demi teinte en demi teinte les réalités
sont quand même je dirais relativement
disparates selon les régions il n'ya pas
d'uniformité
mais quand il en soit l'euphorie n'est
pas n'est pas au rendez vous on peut le
dire
la situation demeure très incertaine les
italiens ont peur pour leur avenir
ils ont déjà fait beaucoup de sacrifices
ils ont déjà fourni énormément d'efforts
et à ce propos je souligne aura une
opposition citoyenne qui est qui a
émergé à ces derniers jours ces deux
dernières semaines
en réaction aux mesures gouvernementales
jugées trop rigide par une partie de la
population qui perd patience qui veut se
remettre vraiment à vivre pleinement et
elle s'est notamment rassemblés derrière
le hashtag tony a molli berry est
redevenu libre sur les réseaux sociaux
elle réclame dès à présent une plus
grande marge de manoeuvre au quotidien
bien sûr dans le respect des mesures de
précaution ouais c'est justement sur ce
chapitre déconfinement à l'italienne
pour en parler nous sommes avec paolo
levi correspondant en france de l'
agence de presse italienne ansa bonsoir
paolo levi les cheveux dans le vent
manifestement sur les toits de paris
vous êtes évidemment aux liaisons
constamment avec vos amis italiens de
compatriotes quel est l'état d'esprit
qui règne en italie
le soulagement mais aussi on imagine
beaucoup de prudence
cela a été très très bien dit depuis
rome votre correspondante a fait une
photo parfaite c'est à dire un clair
obscur c'est à dire d'un côté l'espoir
voilà et surtout une certaine dose
d'optimisme pour cette étape de
confinement pur et dur qui était
finalement enfin franchi après deux mois
de sacrifices incroyables de la part de
la population mais j'ai eu un copain il
m'a appelé ce matin presque les larmes
aux yeux parce qu'il avait pu pour la
première fois depuis plus de 50 jours
allez dans un café où on va tout le
temps boire des cafés le matin et
prendre son café quoique emporté parce
qu'il ne pouvait pas le croire au
comptoir il fallait juste prendre un
gobelet en carton et sortir le siroter
sur le trottoir mais vous devez savoir
que pour les italiens le café c'est un
vrai rythme nationale il n'y a pas de
journée qu'il pas de soleil qui puisse
se lever sans ce café du matin qui est
vraiment que l'emblème même de la
société italienne qui est
voilà qui se redresse chaque matin et va
au travail c'est donc lui m'a appelé
c'était genre une poésie pour lui et m'a
dit écoute je suis l'âge et rien que ce
groupe me ressemble un madeleine
proustienne pas ça faisait 50 jours que
je me faisais le café à la maison qui
bien évidemment est moins bon que celui
du bar à rome
et après donc d'un côté l'optimisme de
l'autre aussi la crainte inquiétude pour
une situation qui est très très fragile
les italiens sont bien conscients que la
phase 2 c'est pas du tout la fin du
confinement hélas il faut faire encore
preuve de de muscles il faut il faut
faire encore un effort parce que le
risque sinon et celui de faire comme
dans le mythe grec de sisyphe quand on
ramène le rapprocher tout en haut de la
montagne elle est ensuite le rocher à
nouveau tombe dans la vallée pour
recommencer tout à zéro
donc c'est une situation très délicate
on pourrait la comparer à celle des
combats les sens qui après la maladie
voilà doivent rester tranquille encore
un petit peu au liés à la maison sont
pas trop faire d'efforts parce que sinon
de voir retomber dans le confinement et
je pense que déjà des conséquences vont
être lourdes estime pour l'économie et
la société italienne et même européenne
et mondiale de plus en général
donc c'est vraiment un moment charnière
où on peut pas trop rigoler las il faut
être fort en corse et on a gagné dix ans
après 50 jours une première bataille
contre l'ennemi invisible une bataille
voilà qui était celle du confinement pur
et dur aujourd'hui on s'apprête à
combattre une deuxième mater et qui est
celle de la phase 2 qui n'est pas la fin
est lasse de la guerre mais voilà on
avance on avance tout doucement ou
ballot paolo levi vous parlez de
l'économie des conséquences alors
laquelle à brens et la vénitie autorisé
la réouverture des restaurants et des
bars alors sans terrain sont précises
parce que dieu seul sait combien c'est
important chez les italiens les
terrasses on imagine que c'est une vraie
catastrophe pour le secteur c'est un
pays avec une culture effectivement très
convivial on se retrouve dans les bars
les restaurants sur sur les piannencs à
un désastre
un désastre je parlais avec ma collègue
dans sa donc de lagence pour laquelle je
travaille les quartier général de mon
agence sont à côté de la fontaine de
trevi et elle elle me dit raconter
aujourd'hui que pour aller au travail
il ya tellement il ya énormément de bar
il doit y avoir ne sais pas comme une
trentaine de bars dans dans un périmètre
c'est donc deux pâtés de maison presque
tellement normalement la requête des
gros centres touristes et romain et
aujourd'hui voilà ces barres même s'ils
pouvaient réouvrir et s'était il était
complètement vide parce que il n'ya pas
il n'y a pas la demande
il ya trop d'offres hélas parce que tous
les touristes rome c'est qu'ils aient
une villa ou si touristique très
touristique s'est vidée de tous ces
touristes et je pense pas qui sait
demain la veille qu'ils vont revenir et
un peu partout non mais on est en train
de vivre il faut en être conscient mais
en train de vivre quelque chose qui est
comparable je pense à la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale aux
destructions et c'est une autre forme de
destruction et de dévastation mais c'est
ça donc d'un côté il faut le savoir avec
avec conscience mais en même temps aussi
espérer qu'après après la guerre il y a
aussi une forme la renaissance et et
l'italie dieu et la france ou si dieu
sait c est les trente glorieuses et le
miracle italien ensuite qu'ils n'ont pas
apporté
voilà à la croissance et le bien-être
extraordinaire qui a été ensuite jamais
pu égaler en europe en tout cas à
l'époque donc l'espoir c'est de
recommencer mais pour cela il est
fondamental de faire preuve de
solidarité une union pas seulement au
niveau national mais même européen et je
dirais même mondial pour la recherche
d'un vaccin qu'il est fondamental aux 60
autres gros coup dur pour l'économie
italienne les écoles elle reste fermée
jusqu'en septembre les eaux étaient plus
radicaux qu'en france en tout cas moins
hésitant comment les parents justement
gère j'imagine le travail l'école des
enfants parce que qui dit enfin la
maison dire la compliqué pour eux
d'aller travailler évidemment oui ils
ont collé à la société italienne par
rapport à la société française
ces deux peuples frères deux peuples qui
ont beaucoup de points en commun
mais la société italienne et les bêtes
elle est plus basé sur la famille donc
il y à tout un réseau familial d'amitié
qui est toujours là c'est notre le vrai
où elle était le vrai état social
italien
il se base avant tout sur sur la
solidarité entre membres de la famille
donc je pense que ils peuvent tenir
comme ça et si les parents c'est surtout
les parents qui ont préféré
voilà le gouvernement il a quelque part
traduit une sensation qui était dans
l'air dans le pays c'était celle que la
mama et le papa je n'avais aucune envie
d'envoyer les enfants à l'école avec ses
risques qui pendent encore sur notre
tête et cet ennemi invisible qui
circulent encore dans dans nos villes et
dans nos pays donc l'italie a fait ce
choix assez radicale mais on va voir en
france qu'est ce que ça va donner 6 6 il
y aura beaucoup d'élèves qui vont se
présenter à l'école ou pas moi j'ai des
doutes franchement mais c'est vrai que
ça va être très intéressant de voir en
tout cas c'est un casse tête énorme pour
les proviseurs moi j'ai lu des lettres
le proviseur ici dans les écoles à paris
c'est rien que d'un point de vue
logistique pour organiser la une à la
sécurité des gosses c'est un truc il
faut einstein
merci paul ollivier en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
merci à vous merci et direction
maintenant les états unis le pays le
plus meurtrier au monde par le virus
donald trump lui reste malgré tout
optimiste hier soir lors d'une émission
spéciale sur fox news le président
américain a prédit un vaccin pour fin
2020 henan et 2021 incroyable sur le
plan économique il s'en est également
pris à nouveau à la chine responsable
selon lui d'avoir caché la vérité sur la
gravité
du virus en ligne de mire la
présidentielle qui aura lieu dans six
mois grégory beaud a touché un nombre
significatif de preuves
ce sont les mots sans appel de mike
pompeo si l'on en croit le chef de la
diplomatie américaine le coronavirus ce
serait bel et bien échappé du fameux
laboratoire chinois de google
n'oubliez pas que ce n'est pas la
première fois que la chine infecte le
monde et qu'elle a l'habitude de gérer
des laboratoires ne respectant pas les
normes
ce n'est pas la première fois que nous
avons un monde exposé à des virus qui
résultent de défaillance d'un
laboratoire chinois et donc pendant que
le comité de renseignements poursuit son
travail
il devrait continuer à procéder à des
vérifications pour que nous en soyons
certains je peux vous dire qu'il y a un
nombre significatif de preuve que cela
vient de ce laboratoire a one des propos
très offensif appuyé par le président
trump lors d'un échange virtuel avec des
américains retransmis ce dimanche soir
sur fox news
une émission qui a eu lieu depuis le
lincoln memorial de washington est
baptisé l'amérique ensemble retourner au
travail
ils ont fait une terrible erreur et non
pas voulu l'admettre
nous voulions y aller mais il ne voulait
pas de nous là bas même l'om est saoul
et y aller
ils ont été admis mais bien plus tard
pas immédiatement
selon moi ils ont fait une erreur qu'ils
ont essayé de courir d'étouffer c'est
comme un incendie comme essayer
d'éteindre un feu
ils n'ont pas pu l'éteindre à ce
week-end l'ambassadeur de chine en
france et ancien maire adjoint de buran
a réfuté les accusations américaines sur
les origines du coronavirus s'il a des
preuves qu'il les montre
mais qu'ils cessent de duper les genres
avec des lessives en poudre
la communauté internationale doit plutôt
poursuivre la responsabilité des états
unis qui ont causé la propagation du
virus dans le monde
ceux qui font du tapage autour du
laboratoire de one sont des politiciens
et des médias et scientifiques estiment
tous que le virus est naturelle le
laboratoire applique les procédures de
sécurité
il n'y est pas question de fuite de
virus et il n'a ni la volonté ni la
capacité de créer ce genre de
coronavirus des échanges diplomatiques
ou le à l'heure où les états unis ont
une nouvelle fois menacé pékin de
lourdes sanctions financières et les
états unis qui ont annoncé détenir des
preuves que le cofidis
c'était bien échappé du laboratoire p4
how one
nous sommes avec caleb un mot pas un
journaliste politique pour arte mairie
casser notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir
quel est mon père merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france adore pour
donald trump 1 non seulement ce sont les
chinois qui ont relâché le virus du
laboratoire de wana mais dans une
interview à fox news il dit en plus
qu'ils ont cherché à dissimuler cette
faute à l'éteindre je cite comme un
incendie mais qu'ils n'ont pas réussi
que vous inspirent ces accusations de la
part du président américain mais il faut
se rappeler qu'en janvier lorsque la
chine gérait la situation ce sont les
médias américains utilisaient que la
chine allait trop loin et que ces
mesures de distanciation extrême était
de relever du totalitarisme en janvier
lorsque apparemment un la chine couvre
et ou étouffer la situation donald trump
a félicité le président pour sa gestion
de la crise
c'est en ce moment alors que le monde
voit que les états unis ont du mal à
gérer la crise qui lie à tes critiques
envers la chine mais c'est nouveau lors
de la période où la chine est tout fait
paraît-il cette situation les stades ne
parle pas du tout alors selon mike popeo
pompéo et donald trump qui existe des
preuves immense 5 ces deux là je cite
que c'est parti est-ce que selon vous on
a une chance que washington produit ces
fameuses preuves
le bureau du renseignement national aux
états unis est très clair cela n'est pas
le cas
beaucoup de voix scientifiques du monde
entier ont également été clair sur ce
fait ce n'est pas un virus génétiquement
modifiés qui n'a pas été créée
artificiellement
c'est un virus naturel
ya beaucoup de théories sur son
apparition a woman mais l'idée selon
laquelle il s'agit d'une arme génétique
a été déboulonnée donald trump et m'a
pompé au ne souhaite pas présenter des
évidences soutenant leurs thèses de
nature indique qu'il n'a pas le droit de
d'en dire plus d'après la constitution
personne n'a autorité sur le président
des états unis il peut présenter toutes
les informations qu'il veut les publier
n'importe quand on dit que l'idée qu'il
aurait beaucoup de preuves démontrant
qu'il s'agit une arme génétique mais
qu'il faut simplement à les croire c'est
absurde c'est complètement fou tous les
experts nous disent que cela n'est pas
le cas alors les experts dont l'om est
d'ailleurs qui juge une nouvelle fois ce
soir spéculative ses déclarations
américaines oms qui a toujours défendu
plutôt la thèse chinoise a en tout cas
est ce que justement le torchon brûle
définitivement entre l'organisation de
la santé et les états unis qui ont
décidé d'ailleurs de ne plus la finance
est on le rappelle la réaction 30 pistes
aux états unis et est très critique de
l'om s était aux nations unies du fonds
monétaire international de la banque
internationale et sont très critiques et
des institutions internationales c'est
c'est là l'aspect nationalistes des
politiques de donald trump steve à
nantes par exemple s'est montré très
critique des institutions
internationales
le parti démocrate est plus proche de
l'union européenne et en règle générale
plus proche des institutions
internationales
dans ce moment de crise et de
frustration autour de cette pandémie
alors que les institutions
internationales sont vraiment mises à
l'épreuve
alors il semble que donald trump fait
avancer
ces idées et essaye de dire qu'il
faudrait blâmer non seulement la chine
mais également les institutions
internationales pour cette pandémie
mais les faits ne soutiennent pas c'est
cette idée alors on est à quelques mois
on le rappelle des élections
présidentielles est ce qu'il n'est pas
commode c'est pas un argument tout
trouvé justement pour se dédouaner de la
gestion de la crise de la part de donald
trump finalement remettre la faute à la
chine et il faut remarquer que la chine
n'a eu aucun avertissement s'agissant de
cette pandémie
elle a commencé en chine à wuhan ils ont
mené les enquêtes ils ont pris leur
temps ils ont alerté le ms et ensuite
ils sont agiles
les etats-unis ont bénéficié de longs
mois pour se préparer et les nous
dirigent 0 il n'y a aucun problème tout
cela sera bien géré mais en coulisses
ils vendaient leurs actions et il se
préparait à d'énormes problèmes
économiques
donc il est très clair que nous
dirigeants sont bien plus coupable
d'avoir mal géré cette épidémie que les
autres ils n'ont pas été honnêtes ils ne
nous ont pas dit le danger que cela
représente et il s'est effectivement de
repousser la faute
mais le parti démocrate le position par
rapport à donald trump aura pour
candidat de dubaï donne beaucoup
d'américains regardent l'action du parti
démocrate et 10
eh bien ils n'ont pas beaucoup mieux
agit donc de notre offre tout cela faute
vers la chine il essaye de dire qu'il
fait du bon travail les démocrates le
critique mais nous ne savons pas comment
cela va se refléter lors des élections
car beaucoup de personnes pensent que
les démocrates ont également mal agi
très rapidement qu'elle aime beaucoup ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui possible aux états
unis de mener campagne d'un côté comme
de l'autre
en pleine crise du coronavirus si les
élections avaient lieu aujourd'hui dans
de telles circonstances
alors ce il ne s'agirait pas d'élections
démocratiques
atik car le pays est toujours cadenassée
mais nous avons encore pas mal de temps
avant novembre et les conventions
démocrate et républicaine lorsque les
démons les candidats seront nominés
reste encore à venir si les élections
avaient lieu aujourd'hui certes ces
élections ne seraient pas invalides cela
ne fait aucun doute beaucoup calais
babou part d'avoir été avec nous on
dirait que pour vu de l'extérieur ce
soir
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons donc sur cette pièce du
coronavirus en france nous ferons
notamment un focus sur le milieu
culturel fortement touché par la crise
sanitaire mais dont on parle finalement
assez peu avec ces festivals annulés ou
reportés les uns après les autres les
salles de cinéma et de spectacles qui
peine à se projeter sur une potentielle
date de réouverture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial pendant la
période actuelle il est difficile de
dire précisément combien d'enfants sont
concernés car en fait on a très peu de
visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le lise
ils redisent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il n'y a plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude un porte
plutôt sur ce que vous vraiment pas la
partie immergée de l'iceberg en fait
parce que les très difficile pour les
enfants malgré tout d'après eux mêmes et
dans ce cas là on n'entend rien ça se
fait totalement dans le silence
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission 21h30
heure française tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi 4 mai
le plan de déconfinement présenté par
edouard philippe cet après midi a été
rejeté par le sénat par 89 voix contre
81 une pour 174 abstention du manque de
masques de protection et de tests en
passant par les ouvertures des écoles le
gouvernement fait face à de nombreuses
critiques concernant l'après 11 mai
alors que la barre des vingt cinq mille
décès a été franchie la crise du corona
virus qui touche de plein fouet le
milieu culturel les festivals ont été
reportés les uns après les autres et les
salles de cinéma et de spectacles bnl à
se projeter sur une potentielle date de
réouverture
mnm et on promet un des premières
décisions à destination du secteur en
souffrance
[Musique]
la barre des 25 mille morts liés aux
copies de 19 a été franchie en france
aujourd'hui le pays déplore 25200 un
décès la direction générale de la santé
annonce ces dernières 24 heures une
hausse du nombre de morts avec 306
nouveaux décès du côté de la carte le
département de l'ardèche passe en verre
en raison de la diminution de la
circulation du virus avec une proportion
de passages aux urgences inférieur à la
barre des 6% et le sénat qui rejette
donc ce soir le plan du gouvernement à
89 voix contre 81 une pour 174
abstentions edouard philippe en avait
détaillé les contours cet après midi au
palais du luxembourg on part tout de
suite sur place voir notre reporter
thomas abonnés bonsoir
thomas que faut-il retenir de cette
journée
une journée plutôt délicate pour le
gouvernement puisque vous l'avez dit le
sénat rejette le plan de déconfinement
du gouvernement 89 voix contre 81 une
voie pour 174 abstention en clair la
droite s'est abstenue et la gauche a
voté contre dans ce qui constitue un
vote non contraignant et dont la portée
est avant tout symbolique les sénateurs
donc pas convaincu par le discours du
premier ministre un discours d'environ
une heure dans lequel edouard philippe a
présenté un certain nombre de mesures
des mesures économiques avec par exemple
une aide de 200 euros à destination de
800 mille jeunes en situation de
précarité des mesures sanitaires
également avec cet objectif 700 mille
tests par semaine ainsi que le fait que
chaque français puisse se procurer un
masque après la date vient du 11 mai
edouard philippe coene a profité
d'ailleurs pour répondre à cette
polémique sur les éventuels stocks
cachés de masques dans la grande
distribution il a également rappelé la
doctrine qui sera en vigueur pour le
port du masque
à l'école on les écoute je les dis nous
fournirons des masques aux personnels de
l'éducation nationale et aux collégiens
pour ces derniers le masque sera
obligatoire quand les restes le de
distanciation sociale risque de ne pas
être respectés pour les élèves des
classes élémentaires le port du masque
n'est pas recommandé il est même
proscrit pour les enfants de maternelle
et j'aimerais répondre aux malentendus
qui a échauffé ce week-end quelques
esprits
peut-être en mal de politiques je dois
dire que je peine à comprendre quel
intérêt aurait eu la grande distribution
a caché des stocks de masques au lieu de
les vendre en temps de pénurie il n'y a
pas et il n'y a jamais eu de stock caché
il y a des commandes massives et il faut
un certain temps avant qu'elle se
concrétise en millions de masques
disponibles pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
suite à ce discours l'opposition a fait
part d'un certain nombre de réserves de
critiques notamment donc sur la question
des masques et plus généralement sur les
contradictions du gouvernement
contradictions entre les discours qui
était tenue au début de cette crise et
les discours qu'y sont tenues
actuellement par l'exécutif
je vous propose d'écouter quelques uns
des membres de l'opposition au sénat
la confiance ne se décrète pas elle se
mérite
or monsieur le premier ministre vous
avez là
je m' entamez votre capital confiance
auprès de l'opinion publique depuis le
début de cette crise les françaises et
les français sont assaillis des
injonctions contradictoires nous pouvons
plus vous croire sur parole parce que
cette parole a fait l'objet de trop de
contradictions de trop de contre-vérités
parfois aussi vous auriez dû dire dès le
départ qu'il y avait un problème de
pénurie il faut en finir avec les
injonctions contradictoires que nous
connaissons depuis plusieurs mois vous
n'avez pas anticipé ce désarroi des
parents des enseignants des élus en
manque de confiance de la part de
l'opposition qui s'est donc traduit par
un rejet lors du vote de ce plan de
déconfinement alors concrètement cela ne
change pas grand chose puisque ce vote
était uniquement consultatif et ne
devrait donc pas contraindre l'exécutif
à revoir sa stratégie en revanche ils
augurent des difficultés à venir sur un
autre vote d'un autre texte ce lundi
soir les sénateurs sont amenés à
s'exprimer sur le projet de loi qui va a
prorogé l'état d'urgence sanitaire pour
une période de deux mois avec notamment
au sein de ce texte la création de
brigades sanitaires qui vont être
chargés de récolter les données des
patients malades ainsi que leur
entourage ou encore la mise en
quarantaine de toutes les personnes qui
arrivent sur le territoire national une
mesure qui avait été annoncée samedi à
l'issue du conseil des ministres et qui
a été corrigé depuis puisque l'elysée a
fait savoir hier soir que finalement
cette mesure ne concernera pas les
personnes qui arrivent sur le territoire
national en provenance de pays de
l'espace schengen ou du royaume uni mais
2 bat les débats devraient donc être
animée puisque 160 amendements au total
ont été déposés sur ce projet de loi à
un sénateur me confier tout à l'heure
qu'il s'attend à ce que les débats
durent très tard ce soir voire jusqu'à
très tôt demain matin et on suivra
évidemment avec votre m'abonner merci à
vous et pour en parler nous sommes avec
denis demonpion éditorialiste politique
bonsoir denis demonpion merci d'être
avec nous en direct les sénateurs qui
ont donc rejeter en ce plan de
déconfinement ce soir vous en êtes
étonné non absolument pas on sait que
depuis maintenant des mois des mois et
oui
même plus d'un an maintenant le premier
adversaire politique dans le pays c'est
le sénat et avec sa tête gérard larcher
donc là c'était j'allais dire une
c'est une défaite qui très peu
significative puisque vous savez que la
constitution ne contraigne est pas
n'obligez pas le gouvernement à comment
dirais-je à un vote qui l'engagé pas
comme un vote de confiance à l'assemblée
ou même au sénat c'était juste une
formalité
une bonne manière que le gouvernement a
fait aux élus comme d'ailleurs le
premier miss en état expliqué la semaine
dernière devant l'assemblée en disant
que les élus quels qu'ils soient députés
ou sénateurs
plutôt que de se livrer à des
conversations genre café du commerce
ils devaient prendre leurs
responsabilités en tant que représentant
de la nation
votez et donc voilà il les a mis devant
leurs responsabilités
d'autres c'était sa part donné - vous
dites c'était symbolique il n'en avait
pas besoin oui on est on est tous
d'accord mais on ces temps difficiles
imedi pour l'histoire du pays est ce que
il n'aurait pas fallu mieux afficher une
sorte d'union sacrée une union nationale
en ce sens à ce que le gouvernement n'a
pas échoué à cela tout simplement
écouter en tout cas le gouvernement et
pas dans une situation facile clair
depuis le début puisque quand on voit
les
leader de l'opposition qui sont
exprimées au sénat cet après midi ils
disent ils reprochent au gouvernement de
ne pas avoir eu à cette visibilité de
s'être contredit de ne pas avoir géré
assez bien la pénurie mais le premier
ministre est en droit de leur répondre
que cette pénurie a quand même été
organisée par tous et sénateurs qui sont
là depuis des années et qui ont été pour
beaucoup dans les gouvernements
précédents
il faut bien reconnaître que c'est vrai
que les manuels macro et son
gouvernement est aux affaires depuis
deux ans et demi
mais les tous les gouvernements
précédents qui vampait notre système de
santé etc
ils ont été les premiers et notamment
d'ailleurs les républicains sous nicolas
sarkozy à réduire le nombre de lits à
fermer des hôpitaux pour des questions
budgétaires
donc il peut leur est facile c'est
presque même indécent d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui de dire voilà il n'ya pas
une masse qui a pas eu de gel
hydroalcoolique
c'est un petit peu court politiquement
quand même en quoi est-ce qu'on
politiquement cette affaire de masse
parce que la polémique rebondit
aujourd'hui encore les masses qui sont
comme par enchantement absolument
disponibles par millions dans la grande
distribution qui ne l'étaient pas pour
les soignants il ya encore quelques
temps
oui bien sûr non mais il est un fait
qu'il ya eu un niveau de masques et de
gels hydroalcooliques et même de blues
d'ailleurs contenu de cette épidémie qui
a submergé les services hospitaliers ça
c'est très clair
maintenant ce n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
que la france est dépendante pour les
médicaments pour tout ce qui est
sanitaire de l'extérieur et notamment de
la chine
ça fait quand même des années on sait
que d'ailleurs vous savez on peut
remonter jusqu'à jacques chirac puisque
c'est lui qui
avait favorisé la construction de ce
laboratoire qui ces polémiques à roanne
qui a permis c'est un laboratoire donc
scientifique pour la recherche des virus
et qui aujourd'hui fait débat puisque
certains ont tendance à penser que le
virus viendrait de la d'envoyer faut
remonter quinze 15 ans ou 17 ans en
arrière ce qui fait quand même beaucoup
quoi alors le déconfinement pourrait
être repoussée si les français se
relâche trop vite c'est ce sont les mots
du ministre de la santé olivier véran
denis demonpion vous l'observateur tout
est vraiment trop la main des français
c'est pas un petit peu facile c'est pas
de façon pour le gouvernement de se
dédouaner tout simplement de sa
responsabilité
écoutez je sais pas je pense que avoir
une vision franco française hexagonal de
ce problème serait un peu dommageable
parce que on voit que il y a des
dizaines de milliers de morts partout en
europe pas seulement en france par
exemple à écouter on voit qu'en italie
par exemple ils en sont à 28 milles et
ce soir il a indiqué qu'ils avaient sous
estimé le nombre de morts de 13000 dont
il en serait à plus de 40 milles des
faits envoyez même chose en grande
bretagne où ils ont dû rectifier est
arrivé aujourd'hui à près de 30000 des
faits donc la france est grosso modo
jalibert dans cette fourchette macabre
mais il faut aussi dire que c'est le
fruit de toute une politique économique
européenne qui a été défaillante
c'est clair il ya là dessus au moment
des explications quand la crise sera
passée
là il y aura quand même un bilan à faire
de tout ça alors pour ce qu'il ya dudit
confinement est ce que
lippi est ce que l'europe est ce que
même les états unis peuvent comment
dirais-je prolonger un confinement qui
pèse beaucoup sur le moral des gens
d'abord et puis qui est très coûteux en
terme social et économique
moi j'ai des informations par exemple
dans les milieux hospitaliers
il ya évidemment on fait le décompte des
victimes du coc vie de tous les jours
des unités de réanimation des barbes et
des gens qui meurent dans les couloirs
et cetera mais il ya aussi tout le reste
c'est à dire les violences faites aux
femmes notamment aux enfants qui ont
explosé depuis bientôt deux mois
et puis tous les gens qui ont des avc
des problèmes autres et qui ne sont pas
soignées donc ça ça pose un problème
sanitaire grave dans ce pays
merci beaucoup denis demonpion d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france et
le secteur culturel n'est pas épargné
par le corps d'un virus c'est même l'un
des domaines les plus fortement touchés
par la pandémie les pertes économiques
s'élèverait déjà à plusieurs centaines
de millions d'euros et l'inquiétude
grandit face à l'absence de réaction de
la part du gouvernement
nicolas d'une claire le monde de la
culture n'a jamais été aussi près du
gouffre festival annulés ou reportés
théâtres salles de cinéma des concerts
fermé plus aucun tournage de films en
france la vie culturelle s'est figée
elle qui pèse 44,5 milliards d'euros et
fait vivre un million trois cent mille
personnes c'est trois fois plus que
l'industrie automobile
stéphane ricordel est aux côtés de sa
compagne laurence de marc galès coup
directeur du théâtre monfort et du
festival paris quartier d'été
jamais ils n'oublieront ce 12 mars où
tout s'est soudain arrêté voilà la salle
est pleine le spectacle est entre à
jouer on s est super tarn à vis du
champagne c'était notre dernière soirée
comment parler de grippette de petites
rues dont on savait pas les masses pas
les masques en tout cas tout allait bien
encore on est tous heureux là on est
tous heureux on et 450 dans la salle
et puis pour le lendemain le lendemain
on est hyper inquiet on va tous chercher
du zèle y en a pas des masses qui en a
pas et on me dit que c'est hyper grave
mais on est apte et depuis on a renfermé
le problème c'est précisément le flou
artistique qui entoure les mesures
concrètes qu'attend le secteur culturel
qui pourra ouvrir comment quelles aides
d'état alors qu'on estime d'ores et déjà
à 590 millions d'euros la perte de
chiffre d'affaires pour le seul secteur
du spectacle vivant privé
des chiffres qui donnent le tournis
beaucoup craignent avoir tiré le rideau
rouge pour de bon on a un ancien
directeur d'un festival donc on avait la
dynamique encore du festival et on ya
cru jusqu'au dernier moment son portrait
dans le déni de cette de cette pandémie
mais en se disant on va peut-être
essayer d'inventer de réinventer c'est
donc on a travaillé son plein
d'hypothèses puisqu'au moment où
effectivement le flou artistique du
ministère de la culture avec des petits
festivals des petits lieux des petites
chaises des petits mons est divorcée
n'importe quoi il n'ya pas de n'a pas
vraiment digne on comprend rien donc on
a été obligé de fait d'annuler au 6e
festival ou moins 2 au mois de juillet
donc en fait on n'a pas de visibilité
aussi bien même pour la rentrée même
inquiétude dans le monde de la musique
le secteur qui était déjà mal en point
voient mal comme horrible
se relever sans la mise en place d'un
véritable plan marshall pour la culture
cette simple flic confiné réalisées aux
quatre coins de la france et visionner
trois millions 600 mille fois sur
youtube sonne comme un appel poétique
mais sans trop d'espoir d'être entendue
au sommet de l'état pour les ministres
de la culture qui sort des grandes
écoles
l'art c'est uniquement l'opéra les
balaie les pièces à un peu chiante
voilà c'est la culture pop eurent
populaire pour eux ça n'existe pas s'il
faut tenir encore un mois c'est
peut-être possible s'il faut tenir un an
c'est sûr que c'est l'hécatombe c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle de
grands noms de la culture ont signé une
tribune publiée le 30 avril dernier dans
le journal le monde un appel à prolonger
d'un an les droits des intermittents du
spectacle pour l'instant aucune réponse
un silence assourdissant que l'on
regarde d'un oeil et au nez depuis
l'allemagne
richard colombelles est un peintre
français installé à berlin
l'état a dès le mois de mars débloqué
une aide d'urgence de 50 milliards
d'euros pour les indépendants du monde
de la culture
noah en allemagne ça a été extrêmement
facile
l'aide a été extrêmement efficace et
rapide
ça a remplacé le salaire de toutes les
personnes qui qui ont des charges à
payer charge d'ateliers charge de de
logement de nourriture
les premiers les nécessités première
dans un tweet posté samedi dernier
emmanuel macron a fait savoir qu'il
dévoilerait ses mesures pour le secteur
culturel ce mercredi 6 mai une
allocation pour le moins attendu et pour
parler du secteur de la culture nous
sommes avec bernard werber écrivain
auteur de la célèbre trilogie les
fourmis bonsoir bernard werber à ses
côtés avec par skype également dans 21
producteur de comédies musicales bonsoir
à vous aussi alors la culture qui a été
jusqu'à présent parce que on s'est un
petit peu rattrapé ces derniers jours du
côté du gouvernement ça a été les grands
oubliés en ce plan de déconfinement en
tout cas annoncés par edouard philippe
lors de son discours le 28 avril déjà
selon vous pourquoi ce retard à
l'allumage
dove attia je pense qu'ils étaient très
occupés et pour eux on n'était peut-être
pas prioritaire c'est la seule raison
que je trouve bernard werber domaine de
la culture qui fait vivre 1,3 million de
personnes en france en dans une tribune
au journal le monde de nombreux artistes
ont déploré le manque de soutien du
gouvernement vous vous l'expliquez
comment à je ne sais pas je ne suis pas
dans les petits secrets du gouvernement
mais je pense qu'en effet ils vivent une
crise qui est vraiment nouvelle dans
lequel il
tout est inventé ce qui se passe c'est
que en effet la culture tout à l'heure
le votre invité précédent disait qu'il y
avait beaucoup de problèmes
psychologiques chez les gens qui rester
chez eux de dépression il faut voir que
la culture sert aussi à ça souvent la
culture ça arrive en parent pauvre parce
qu'on se dit c'est pas nécessaire comme
la nourriture ou la santé ou la sécurité
mais c'est nécessaire pour la solidité
psychologique précisément pour ne pas se
disputer à la maison pour avoir une
évasion
actuellement la culture c'est ce qui
permet aux gens de tenir c'est parce
qu'il voit des films parce qu'ils lisent
des livres parce qu'ils écoutent de la
musique que ils sont peut-être un peu
plus détendu sinon livrer un stress qui
serait beaucoup plus difficile à gérer
mais encore faut-il soutenir les
artistes c'est quand un secteur
extrêmement fragile dans lequel je pense
va y avoir beaucoup de blessés et
beaucoup de noms alors c'est sûr que
personne ne voit de quoi vous parlez
évidemment pas de pas de dispute chez
personne à la maison d'env attia au
japon en tenez par exemple il ya des
pièces de théâtre qui ont été joués en
public retransmise en direct sur
internet est ce que ça manque un petit
peu de deux ça finalement en france
d'ailleurs on a très peu entendu le
ministre de la culture un s'exprimer oui
c'est vrai qu'on a été les grands
oubliés donc je comprends qu'il ya des
choses plus urgentes au japon oui
je connais bien puisque une pièce un
spectacle dont je suis le co auteur qui
va diffuser sur les chaînes de télé pour
pallier à la fermeture de théâtre bon et
puis la catastrophe pour nous c'est
cesser toutes ces intermittents ces gens
qui font vivre notre métier qui ont un
système un peu compliqué avec ce qu'on
appelle intermittence avec les 507
heures qu'ils doivent faire
pendant dix voix avec une date
anniversaire est là depuis on va dire
début mars il ne travaille plus donc non
seulement ils n'ont pas de revenus mais
en plus ils ne peuvent pas avoir un
chantage puisqu'il faut avoir fait cette
507 heures j'espère et je pense que le
président va s'exprimer sur ce point
comment faire que ces personnes qu'ils
soient qui sera indispensable à notre
métier m'a la culture
robin de spectacles de musique de
plateau télé de tournage cinéma pour
kiel qui crèvent pas quoi parce que
c'est n'ont rien et c'est pas que les
sociétés papier potters qui les
pointures ne peuvent rien faire s'il n'y
a pas les artistes des techniciens temps
effectivement emmanuel macron annoncé
qu'il prendrait la parole le 6 mai avec
des annonces pour le milieu de la
culture bernard werber vous en entendez
quoi du président de la république
en effet une aide au monde et l'édition
mais je crois aussi il va falloir donner
un coup de main aux libraires qui sont
en première ligne et qui sont les
premiers à s'offrir à souffrir de de
cette crise il ya comme idée de bâtir il
ya tous les gens qui sont dans l'ombre
qui vont aussi répercuté le fait que la
culture n'arrive pas à vivre ce que
j'attends évidemment c'est que c'est une
puisse y avoir une solidarité une aide
aussi avec des artistes etc et que la
culture prennent une place un peu plus
importante en est chez dans les
préoccupations du gouvernement
alors justement vous dites de l'aide à
l'édition on imagine que de nombreux de
nombreux des millions
deux lecteurs avaient envie peut-être
davantage de l'irs avait peut-être plus
le temps est ce que vous avez quelques
informations justement sur peut-être
plus de téléchargements sur des
tablettes ou ou tout simplement les
livres vendus en grande distribution qui
ont augmenté leurs ventes bernard verley
écouter du pigeon c'est moi j'ai les
informations utiles viennent que que des
médias petit peu que j'en sais je crois
qu'en effet il ya eu beaucoup plus de
vente de deux livres en audio et des
ventes de livres en numérique
tout simplement parce que c'est le seul
moyen de d'avoir du choix
je crois qu'en effet peut-être les
habitudes des français vont changer au
niveau des livres ils vont découvrir
en effet l'utilisation de ces nouveaux
outils sas à risque en effet d'être mais
ce que c'est bon pour les pour les
libraires ça c'est encore une autre
question mais pas forcément d'ailleurs
effectivement les libraires qui sont
restés fermés dans notre pays c'était
mauvaises décisions d'un maintien selon
vous on aurait du genre vient la
question initiale faire peut-être
davantage pour la culture c'est vrai
qu'il ya pas eu beaucoup d'initiatives
on a vu des rediffusions de vieux films
notamment sur le service public mais peu
de chose en direct on aurait peut-être
pu finalement on faire des concerts à
distance entre les musiciens les
diffuser est-ce que je vais assez plein
d'initiatives
je ne sais pas parce que je veux dire et
man ont été beaucoup être obsessionnel
son lymphome je suis moi je suis en
panne création je connais beaucoup de
créateurs on n'arrivait plus à créer
pourtant les temps qu'on filme ans parce
que on a pensé pied un chacun ça se
passera un traumatisme
ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui c'est unique ça
est unique dans le 21e siècle c'est
quelque chose d'incroyable ce que l'on
vit et donc on est sûrement en train de
vivre un traumatisme dont se rend pas
encore compte donc je pense qu'on est
tous tournés vers la foule puis la
recherche surtout médicales
scientifiques
on espérait qu'on essaie de trouver un
signe d'espoir et aujourd'hui pour faire
un petit lien de mon métier je compare
avec des producteurs
en art pour qu'une visibilité on sait
pas du tout où on va et je crois que
personne ne le sait mais les médecins ne
savent pas même les chercheurs ne savent
pas on est complètement dépendant de la
recherche scientifique et en septembre
même si on autorise les théâtres si le
poème du virus n'est pas résolu qui va
acheter les billets de peu de concerts
de spectacles
c'est là notre problème c'est que ce
comme disait la lame dans notre
reportage on nous n'avons aucune
visibilité
bernard werber le mot de la fin déjà
d'un matière se plaignaient de ne pas
avoir finalement tant d'inspiration ça
pendant cette période de confinement
l'écrivant que vous êtes vous avez été
inspiré oui c'est plus facile pour le
métier d'écrivain pas c'est un métier un
peu de moi dans lequel on est déjà
souvent dans un lieu confiné d'habitude
je vais travailler tous les matins en
allant au café donc là je reste chez moi
à travailler en famille c'est un peu
plus compliqué mais j'ai fini par
trouver un nouveau rythme et j'ai
démarré un livre des débuts du
confinement qui a rien à voir avec le
sujet de confinement mais dans lequel
j'ai eu l'impression que cette ambiance
différente femme oblige à penser
différemment
je crois que comme disait de matières de
toute façon personne ne sait comment
comment ça va se passer après et moi
aussi je suis très attentif pour pour
essayer de voir comment ça va changer
déjà les mentalités est ce que les
mentalités ont changé et ça on va s'en
rendre compte des comptes sera 100
filles merci en tout cas à tous les deux
merci doivent être remerciés vers sa
mère d'arrêter c'est tout merci à vous
et on termine avec une belle initiative
ça fait du bien du jour elle vient de
suite si elle pourrait intéresser les
familles françaises
une remorque un contenaire qui voyagent
avec une belle pièce aménagée dédié
notamment aux personnages âgées aux
personnes âgées pardon ces dernières
peuvent retrouver leur famille en toute
sécurité une baie vitrée est enseignée
au milieu pas de prise de risque donc
les mesures de distanciation sociales
sont respectés et le contact et donc
renoué après des semaines et des mois
d'inquiétude
également appelée happy day room ce
concept a été
créée dans le cadre d'une émission
rapide est diffusée cette fois par an
sur la télévision suisse
et pour en parler nous sommes avec rémy
fabrique un président directeur général
de team cosmo zurich bonsoir et michael
caine merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france comment vous est venue cette idée
de boîte
bonjour madame d'abord bas j'ai été
contacté par la modératrice de rebih d
une des mes amis qui connaissait mon
projet avec un ex compagne à qui était
déjà à fait ce qu'on est
de ce côté-là été au centre d'une
campagne d'engagement que j'avais conçu
par la campagne de magda il ya deux ans
après l'avoir eue avec le producteur de
l'émission il était clair que je vais le
reconstruire et nous utiliserons pour
évider alors comment sont-elles conçu ce
qu'elles peuvent voyager à travers le
pays par exemple
ben oui comme dit mon ami soit son
mobile ces boîtes elles elles peuvent
voyager à travers donc le pays on disait
oui alors c'est moi de son mobile nous
étions maintenant à neuf endroits nous
mettons le continent sur un chargeur
surbaissé et nous pouvons l'utiliser à
travers la suisse et ne se diriger
chaque destination
alors on imagine que ça a créé 2 2 et
des émules peut-être d'autres pays vous
ont contacté parce qu'on sait que c'est
une citation situation extrêmement
compliquée notamment pour les personnes
âgées
la réponse au spectacle a été énorme sur
tous les commentaires sur des canaux
sociales ont montré le besoin des
familles de se revoir
nous allons le faire car les conditions
sont les mêmes partout et nous avons
fait un projet mobile maintenant pour du
simple et moins cher et nous recherchons
des sponsors
alors justement pour l'instant comment
sont-elles financez vous dites vous
chercher des sponsors ça veut dire qu'il
ya des appels un petit peu vous
vous appeler aux pouvoirs publics par
exemple oui ensuite vous avez été
financée par mc saïda télévision suisse
mais pour les pays étrangers nous
recherchons des gens tels que les bandes
des compagnies d'assurance ou des ces
six sociétés télécommunications dont le
but de leur communication d être là pour
les gens intel d'action est plus
crédible que de faire des publicités qui
prétend seulement être là pour les gens
merci beaucoup rémy frappé quand d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
merci à vous c'est la fin de cette
émission on peut écouter vous le savez
en raison de cette crise du coronavirus
nous aussi nous adaptons et les
programmes continuent tout de même
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
demain 8 heures du matin heure française
excellente fin de soirée sur rtl france
on dit que quand la vie de l'un pas dur
il faut se rendre dans un cimetière
ouadhias salam est immense c'est le plus
grand cimetière où l'irak abrite le plus
grand cimetière au monde
argent terre les morts c'est notre vie
les fossoyeurs de père en fils de
ouadhias salam sont les ultimes témoins
des conflits armés survenus en irak